on veut souligner encore que notre
présence à chicago sera pacifique mais
qu'on ait ou pas les autorisations
on sera présent chicago 1968 en marge de
la convention nationale du parti
démocrate
de violentes manifestations opposent des
milliers de jeunes aux autorités à
l'époque de la côte shalit était à
chicago n'a participé à touchant les
manifestations confronté surtout la
police la police d'état et la garde
nationale
ce procès est une motivation politique
s'en est suivi un procès contre les
organisateurs de la contestation qui est
entré dans les annales
le procès des sept de chicago et
l'administration nixon qui étaient
résolus à bloquer les dissidents à à
l'endroit de la guerre du vietnam qui
ont insisté à faire le procès s'était
véritablement ashotian procès politique
un procès spectacle qui tourne aussi
mené par un juge partiale conservateur
et raciste le monde entier nous regarde
oui c'est aussi un slogan de mouvements
ainsi guère aidé de mouvement de la
nouvelle gauche
oui parce qu'ils étaient sensibilisés au
fait que c'était la publicité qui guider
l'opinion publique qui guident et les
actions politiques
le film réalisé par aaron sorkin le
scénariste des séries de west wing news
l'oms et du film hugo de même montre le
racisme le conservatisme et la volonté
de mater l'opposition à la guerre du
vietnam d'une franche du gouvernement
américaine l'époque c'est pas
encyclopédique c'est à dire que même à
aaron sorkin lui-même disait que c'est
plus une peinture qu'une photo donc pris
certaines libertés historique mais
toutefois le cas de respecter cette
inquiète un peu la répression
disproportionnée c'est la gauche dite
radicale ces gens qui manifestent et on
a une dose de black panther rythme pour
pouvoir les rendre plus radicaux et plus
épeurant aux yeux de la société
même si 50 ans se sont écoulés depuis
ces événements il résonne encore avec
pertinence enchante le mouvement
commencé des années 60 70
le projet occupa et puis là aujourd'hui
fait clair pour moi ça va continuer tout
ça liszt les racines
sont là ils ont été posées des années 70
la bête en tain de furir maintenant
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre selon moi
on leur fournit exactement ce qu'ils
veulent une tribune et un auditoire mais
vous croyez qu'il y aura beaucoup de
monde ici labit alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal